lui veut savoir et a demandé aux
services de renseignement un rapport
sous 90 jours tout en déplorant une
nouvelle fois le manque de coopération
et de transparence de pékin si
l'hypothèse d'une fuite d'un laboratoire
a été jugée improbable elle reste sur la
table
c'est une fin de non-recevoir après sept
années de pourparlers la suisse met fin
à ses négociations sur ses relations
avec l'union européenne
berne qui estiment que cela mettrait
notamment en péril ses politiques
migratoires et que cela nuirait à la
protection de ses salaires plus élevés
qu'ailleurs en europe
une décision que regrette bruxelles
[Musique]
repris aujourd'hui du beauvau de la
sécurité pour renouer le dialogue les
syndicats de police ont rencontré le
ministre de l'intérieur et le garde des
sceaux
pour plus de précisions retrouve tout de
suite david khalifa en direct de la
place beauvau bonsoir david un contexte
tendu donc pour ce bobo de la sécurité
une prise de parole attendue du garde
des sceaux
face aux syndicats de police comment
s'est déroulée cette réunion
et bien comme on pouvait s y attendre
une ambiance assez électrique un huit
jours seulement après le rassemblement
des forces de l'ordre devant l'assemblée
nationale et le ministre de la justice a
d'ailleurs tout de suite mis les points
sur les i concernant les agissements de
certains syndicats de police durant
cette manifestation écouter
j'ai dit au fond que l'émotion ne
justifiait pas mais pouvait expliquer un
certain nombre de débordements qui m'ont
déplu
cette scène où l'on voit la justice va
lire une scène de crime
elle est indigne l'expression qui
consiste à dire que c'est un coup de com
c'est indigne des choses qui ont été
dites sont insupportables pour moi la
liberté syndicale
elle n'est pas totale elle est
essentielle elle est importante il faut
prendre en compte les revendications
qu'elle exprime mais pas au détriment de
la république la république c'est notre
bien commun et pardon pour cette
familiarité mais s'il on dézingue les
institutions de la république
alors on dézingue la république des
maudits règlement adressé à fabien
vanhemelryck le secrétaire national du
syndicat alliance police nationale
auteur de cette fameuse phrase dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure
là le problème de la police c'est la
justice un présent aujourd'hui place
beauvau l'objectif était justement de
crever cet abcès mais après cinq heures
de la discussion le syndicaliste est
ressorti un déçu pour lui peu de concret
concernant ses revendications et et
notamment l'allongement à 30 ans de la
mesure de sûreté des condamnés à
perpétuité pour un crime sur un gendarme
ou un policier ou encore la limitation
de certaines réductions de peine et la
fin des rappels à la loi écouter le
signal donné c'est un discours que leur
forme et qui fait qu'on n'y arrivera pas
qu'on continuera à avoir des drames à
avoir une situation calamiteuse et des
collègues laissé sur le tapis on n'a
toujours pas de signal fort envers les
individus et les agresseurs de policiers
la solution ils ne l'ont pas apporté je
ne vois pas comment ils peuvent la
porter et même son cloche pour les
autres syndicats qui restent sur leur
faim david même si
certains saluent un échange intéressant
intéressant mais loin d'être
satisfaisant stéphanie même frustrant
selon les mots d'unité sgp police cette
réunion laisse un goût amer pour la
police est pour rappel elle avait pour
but d'afficher l'unité d'améliorer la
collaboration police justice est bien
l'objectif est loin d'être atteint
puisque cette rencontre on peut le dire
a tourné à l'affrontement
la principale revendication est l
exécution des peines on en parle et là
tout à l'heure et pour répondre à ces
remontrances et bien le ministre de la
justice s'est appuyée sur des chiffres
sans rapporter de réponse claire
dans la globalité des peines qui sont
prononcés dans notre pays je vous ai
donné chiffres la justice est plus dure
peut-être pas aussi dur que vous le
souhaiteriez mais il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que celle que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle l'indépendance
voilà vous l'aurez compris un peu
d'avancé dans cette discussion le
dialogue semble toujours aussi est
difficile gérald darmanin qui était
présent aux côtés d'eric dupond-moretti
a une nouvelle fois affiché à son
soutien aux forces de l'ordre et a
réaffirmé sa volonté de protéger au
maximum la police en mettant en point
d'orgue la loi sécurité globale mais là
aussi c'est loin d'être suffisant pour
les syndicats de police elle se beauvau
de la sécurité n'a pour l'instant pas
l'effet escompté pour l'exécutif a tout
comme pour les forces de l'ordre merci
david khalifa en direct de la place
beauvau alors question l'état est-il un
puissant pour assurer la sécurité des
français faut-il mettre à contribution
les citoyens n'y at il pas là une dérive
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
avec nous pour en parler alexandre
vincent deh vous êtes le maire et
républicains de rillieux-la-pape près de
lyon françois cocq enseignants et
céistes ancien maire-adjoint de
champigny sur marne
bonsoir à tous les deux messieurs merci
d'être avec nous je le disais alexandre
vincent dès qu'il met rhin qui a
déclenché la polémique 1 depuis 24
heures en tout cas le débat après
plusieurs épisodes de violences urbaines
et de menaces dans votre ville monsieur
le maire vous avez décidé d'agir vous
appelez vos administrés à dénoncer les
délinquants via la nouvelle plate forme
de signalement de la police nationale
expliquez-nous votre démarche
le démarche elle est assez simple après
ou connaissez l'emballement médiatique
c'est que on commence expliquer un peu
les choses et puis tout de suite on
entend les montres en acier avec la
référence aux heures les plus sombres de
notre histoire avec la délation
on est pas du tout là dedans vous savez
j'étais sur le ces dernières semaines à
rillieux la pape comme ailleurs en
france il ya actuellement des violences
urbaines ces violences urbaines où on a
senti des véhicules où on s'attaque aux
forces de police
j'ai vécu moi mal puisque j'ai été
jusqu'à encore trois heures du matin
samedi dernier sur le terrain auprès des
habitants et aux côtés des policiers des
forces de l'anp est ce que j'ai pu
constater au delà de ce qu'on voit sur
les images de caméras de vidéoprotection
c'est au delà de la violence c'est pour
parfois le jeune âge de certains des des
personnes qui s'adonnaient à ces
violences et moi ce qui m'a ce qui m'a
choqué je dire quand je suis rentré chez
moi
samedi soir j'ai très peu d'armes très
peu dormi
d'abord par colère vis-à-vis des
habitants et à cause de ces violences
mais aussi en me disant mais comment des
jeunes aussi jeunes peuvent-ils
peuvent-ils continuer comme ça et
comment vont-ils finir et au bout du
compte je me suis dit finalement il faut
aussi en appelle à la responsabilité de
chacun et premièrement des parents le
vrai sujet qu'on a aujourd'hui
si vous avez des très jeunes dans les
quartiers qui notamment depuis le
premier confinement ont été pris en main
par les plus anciens les plus âgées qui
sont souvent de jeunes majeurs ces
jeunes majeurs sont souvent en lien avec
le trafic de stupéfiants 30 dollar
il utilise avec un cynisme absolu les
plus jeunes
les mineurs qui l'ont récupérée pour
certains par les premiers confinement et
ils s'en servent ils s'en servent
excusez moi l'expression comme de la
chair à canon et ces jeunes cantillon
qui ont parfois 12 13 14 ans moi je me
refuse à faire en sorte qu'on les
abandonne savez je pars du principe que
ceux qui peuvent nous aider
aux côtés des collectivités et des
forces de l'anp de la justice essaie de
les remettre dans le droit chemin et en
tout est à faire en sorte qu'il ne brise
pas leur destin ce sont avant tout les
parents
personne ne s'offusque quand vous voyez
une jeune femme se faire agresser dans
la rue ou comme on l'a vu récemment à
paris ce terreau violé personne ne
s'offusque que vous appeliez les forces
de l'ordre pour faire ce signalement
pour appeler à l'aide
parce qu'il y à assistance à personne en
danger quand vous êtes chez vous et que
vous entendez à côté de la paroisse dans
l'appartement d'à côté travers la paroi
de votre hymne de votre appartement
un père de famille violer son enfant ou
passé à tabac s'accompagne et bien vous
prenez votre téléphone
et puis vous après les services de
secours pour les renseigner pour leur
demander d'intervenir bien je pense que
c'est exactement la même chose pour les
jolies mineurs qui aujourd'hui sont en
train de tomber dans l'ultra violence le
but est bien sortis de leur porter
assistance
parce que le vrai sujet c'est de sauver
ses enfants françois cocq c'est bien
effectivement de s'expliquer parce que
comme disait monsieur le maire on rentre
vite dans les polémiques et les
jugements à l'emporte-pièce
d'une certaine manière c'est aussi une
assistance à personne en danger certains
jeunes qui pourraient gâcher leur vie en
devenant des criminels 11 ans pardon
d'expression à jour une connerie
qu'est ce que vous en pensez une idée
forcément mauvaise écoute et si je peux
partager le constat de monsieur le maire
je suis j'ai été élu à champigny
toujours enseignants dans l'un de ces
quartiers qui est l'un de ceux dans
lesquels il ya une vie particulièrement
active et malheureusement nous avons
payé un lourd tribut encore ces derniers
jours à champigny sur marne avec le
décès de plusieurs jeunes mais toujours
est il que si on peut partager le
constat je ne partage pas l'analyse
c'est à dire que l'enseignant que je
suis ce qu'il a sous les yeux quand il
voit un enfant dysfonctionné ça traduit
à chaque fois je le dis bien à chaque
fois un dysfonctionnement de la cellule
familiale
derrière et donc se tourner
immédiatement
les parents en leur disant à vous de
faire le boulot derrière avoue de
reprendre les choses en main tout cela
fonctionnerait si les parents est en
capacité de le faire
la vérité éducative c'est qu'ils ne le
sont pas et s'ils ne le sont pas c'est
qu'il y a besoin dans ce cas-là
d'intermédiation et le problème de ces
quartiers que vous évoquez monsieur le
maire c'est que désintermédiation qui
sont de fait les services publics la
police la justice l'éducation tendait le
bien les collectivités territoriales
avec ce que vous devez j'imagine mettre
en place dans votre ville et ce qui est
le cas dans toutes les villes dans
lesquelles il ya des quartiers
populaires et bien tout cela aujourd'hui
est insuffisant parce que ces zones ne
sont pas des territoires perdus de la
république
ce sont des territoires de relégation
spatiale sociales géographiques
économiques mais aussi des territoires
de relégation pour les services publics
et donc la prise en charge doit aussi
s'organiser ce ne soit ce n'est pas
parce qu'il ya un manquement de l'état
aujourd'hui là dedans que l'on peut dire
aux citoyens qu'ils doivent se saisir de
cette question et je le lui dire en
ajoutant un dernier mot c'est qu'on
vient de voir le reportage et qui a
précédé notre notre discussion
dans celui ci on voit des choses
extrêmement dangereuses et malsaines
dans ce pays où l'opposition pro la
police et la justice
je viens de voir qu'est un sondage qui
vient de sortir et qui a été réalisé par
doxa qui voudraient opposer l'un et
l'autre on voudrait opposer de manière
manichéenne la sécurité et la liberté
je crois que l'on ne s'en sortira pas si
on procède de la sorte est aujourd'hui
en l'appel que vous lancez aux parents
et d'une manière plus générale au
citoyen est un appel qui contribuent à
ce climat ambiant dans le sens où ce
n'est pas à l'individu qu'il faut en
appeler c'est aux citoyens or le citoyen
il est membre de la communauté politique
et il faut que l'on continue à regarder
notre voisin en égal en citoyenneté en
égalant citoyenneté et non pas en un
individu qui potentiellement pourrait
être soit fautif soit délateur donc je
pense que c'est une perte dans laquelle
il ne faut pas apporter de l'eau aux
vents mauvais qui sont ceux qui déjà
aujourd'hui traverse notre pays
alexandre vincent deh il ya aussi l'idée
qu'ils aient vécu et dans votre
initiative dans votre proposition
d'un état finalement impuissant non cela
strictement rien à voir a fait
d'ailleurs je mon interlocuteur déjà
envoyé deux choses qui me choquent
premièrement qui nous dit qu'il faut
surtout faut surtout ne rien dire braves
gens dormez tranquilles ne déposez
jamais plainte si vous voyez une
agression détourner le regard
si vous voyez qu'un jeune est en grande
difficulté ne dit rien mais dans quel
monde on vit
mais il ya malgré moi monsieur le maire
mais je vous fais remarquer que ces
migrations sur la question
juste à temps si vous m'avez pas coupé
donc je pense qu en cours vous n'avez
pas que vos élèves des coupe la parole
et je pense que ça serait bien que vous
puissiez me rendent à paris s'il vous
plaît comme ça on aura un dialogue
constructif et on pourra on pourra
échanger nos arguments mais en attendant
c'est ce que vous avez dit elle dans la
gestion parentale et pas sur l'a4 en
général si je peux juste en place celui
de m'excuser parce que sinon si vous
prenez juste la parole et puis que vous
êtes vous ne venez pas la contradiction
ça va poser un problème dans le débat et
de compréhension de la part des
téléspectateurs
je dis simplement que y'a un moment
justement un citoyen d'ailleurs c'est
donc en tant que mère par exemple
l'article 40 du code pénal
j'ai des responsabilités si par exemple
j'ai connaissance d'un délit et bien si
je ne leur si je n'invente pas la
justice où les forces de l'ordre
je suis pénalement responsable quand
vous êtes parent ou quand vous êtes un
citoyen qui voit qu'un enfant est en
train de de commettre des choses qui
sont délictuelle votre devoir de citoyen
notamment sur un enfant pour qu'on
puisse le sauver pour qu'on puisse
intervenir pour qu'on puisse cesser la
violence
et bien c'est un moment et bien se
tourner vers les institutions et
notamment vers la police et la justice
et des collectivités vous savez dans ces
quartiers oui tu avais dans ses cartes
qu'il ya des dysfonctionnements etc
attendez qu'on va arrêter juste trente
secondes la caricature oui dans ces
quartiers de grandes difficultés
je suis maire du puy maintenant c'est en
effet l'ancien des plus grand plan de
rénovation urbaine de l'agglomération
lyonnaise on est en train de refaire les
écoles on a lancé et on a ouvert il ya
moins il ya un peu plus d'un mois une
médiathèque flambant neuf où on va avoir
une exposition d'envergure nationale
dans l'est dans les mois qui viennent on
met en place énormément dispositif est
dans ces quartiers je peux vous le dire
des gens extraordinaires bien sûr qu'ils
sont en grande difficulté sociale
bien sûr qu'il ya des mères de famille
elle est celle qui viennent par l'ong
sur le sur le plateau qui aujourd'hui
nous invite qui parfois viennent très
tôt sont des mères de familles parfois
seuls qui se lève à 4 heures du matin
pour venir faire le ménage et qui ne
voient pas leurs enfants partir à
l'école il ya des personnes qui se
saignent aux quatre veines dans ces
quartiers pour pouvoir faire en sorte
que leurs enfants réussissent et ses
enfants moi je les vois il compose la
majorité des habitants de ces quartiers
des familles qui font tout pour que
leurs enfants réussissent un cerf
éduquent leurs enfants parce qu'ils ont
compris qu'en tant que parent leur
première responsabilité est d'assurer
d'assurer l'éducation et l'avenir de
leurs enfants
au delà de ça il ya des parents qui
peuvent être sincèrement difficulté et
je rencontre chaque semaine cela moi je
le dis si vous avez besoin d aide
nous vous tendons la main pour qu'on
puisse y ont sauvé votre enfant mais
au-delà de ça en tant que parent si
voyez votre enfant des rires il ya aussi
de votre responsabilité de vous
reprendre en main moi je vais prendre
l'exemple de la maman de la petite
margerie qui était cette maman qui était
d'une dignité extraordinaire alors que
sa fille venait de se faire poignarder
par un jeune adolescent de 13 14 ans
savait elle n'a pas accusé la justice
elle n'a pas accusé la police elle n'a
pas accusé d'une liste de l'intérieur
ministre de la justice ou la société
dans son ensemble
ça nous on essaye de se décharger de
tout elle a dit simplement et où les
parents et les vos enfants occupez vous
de vos enfants demander où sont ils de
soir mais c'est ça le vrai message vous
trouvez normal quand on est parents
qu'on ne se comporte comme un géniteur
moi je trouve pas moi je suis désolé
mais dans les quartiers j'en parlais
encore avec une association aujourd'hui
quand vous avez des enfants de seulement
3 ans ou quatre ans qui sont laissés
seuls dans la rue et que les acteurs
sociaux se retrouva à gérer ces enfants
qui sont quasiment abandonné mais dites
nous en tant que citoyens et acteurs
publics
mais notre devoir c'est de faire des
signalements ont avant le faisais pas de
signalement sur les femmes battues
maintenant on le fait on ne sait pas de
signalement sur l'inceste
maintenant il serait peut-être temps
aussi de le faire pour des enfants qui
aujourd'hui sont abandonnés il serait
peut-être temps aussi connaît un
nécessaire sursaut parental parce que le
vrai sujet c'est qu'on doit travailler
bien sûr avec les collectivités la
police la justice et c'est un continuum
de noter curité mais aussi un continuum
de responsabilités y compris dans ces
quartiers est là
les citoyens prennent toute leur place
avec honda citoyens qui met à l'honneur
un prix vont vos deux messages en tout
cas et vos points de vue pourraient
faire avancer un peu ce débat dans
l'allier un certainement de ce que vous
proposez depuis le 4 mars dernier une
plate forme et met à disposition des
citoyens pour s'y noyer ce site il n'ya
les pardons cette fois les points de
deal un gérald darmanin avait expliqué
sa démarche au parisien à l'époque les
citoyens doivent être actif dans ce
combat contre la drogue mais nous devons
leur donner les moyens de nous aider en
gros françois cocq c'est toujours la
même chose il ya une forme d'impuissance
de la part des services de l'état et
désormais on en appelle aux citoyens
vous le lisez comme ça non cette
interprétation est beaucoup trop facile
s'il ya une puissance de l'état c'est
que ceci a été organisé depuis des
années enfin qui a organisé la casse de
la police républicaine dans ce pays qui
a limité les effectifs qui a fait des
regroupements de deux zones de sécurité
qui sont absurdes et qui sont
déconnectés du terrain tout ce qu'on
connaît depuis maintenant une quinzaine
d'années et qu'on connaît surtout nos
territoires
donc aujourd'hui l'impuissance de l'état
a été organisé et on glisse et aux
citoyens d'agir
eh bien il ya là un vrai danger et je
suis désolé mais votre intervention
monsieur le monsieur le maire en atteste
vous avez commencé à nous dire c'est aux
parents d'agir et puis immédiatement
vous avez dit c'est aux citoyens de
venir agir et de dénoncer mais là on
rentre dangereuse dans un jeu
extrêmement dangereux si nous livrons à
ça nous ne pouvons pas nous passer
aujourd'hui d'une un terme et d'une
intermédiation qui permettrait de
concilier la force et le droit c'est
tout le rôle c'est toute la construction
de la police républicaine depuis plus de
deux siècles dans ce pays est
aujourd'hui nous pourrions rentrer dans
un modèle complètement à l'anglo saxonne
où nous comporterons comme des individus
atomisés en train en train de regarder
l'un et l'autre en chiens de faïence je
crois que c'est une grave erreur et que
les manquements de l'état ne peuvent pas
aujourd'hui être compensée par les
citoyens nous sommes dans un moment on a
besoin d'une refondation républicaine et
d'une refondation populaire chacun le
voit bien et s'ils ne viennent bien
mauvaise manière de s'y prendre que
d'une certaine manière de permettre aux
citoyens d'être monter les uns contre
les autres
vous savez les sujets excusez moi mais
si je peux juste répondre moi vous savez
je vais pas partir on est grand
débat philosophique ou des grands débats
partisans aussi j'ai peut-être beaucoup
moins intelligent vous est beaucoup
moins instruits c'est vrai mais j'ai
quand même une certaine expérience de
terrain
le savez il ya quinze jours je vous
racontais une petite expérience il ya
quinze jours on a réussi à nettoyer un
point de lille complètement et à mettre
en prison ceux qui s'adonnaient au
trafic de stupéfiants et qui essayait de
mettre en coupe réglée plusieurs
immeubles
ça faisait plus d'un an qu'on travaille
avec les habitants et grâce pour
remonter l'information des habitants
non pas que la police n'a pas les moyens
d'avoir des informations mais la police
ça si on met un policier dans la cage
d'escalier le dealer il ira dans une
autre cage d'escalier donc on devra
mettre un policier dans chaque cage
d'escalier ça c'est juste pas possible
vous n'avez aucun état par un état
totalitaire qui peut il réussir à faire
ça donc on a travaillé avec les citoyens
on à travers des choses que je peux voir
et ils nous en donner des éléments
derrière nous avons été déclenché une
enquête judiciaire
il ya eu enquête interpellations des
ferments condamnation et emprisonnements
et on a travaillé tous ensemble qui
oblige aujourd'hui les gens nous
remercient
ça veut dire que les citoyens ont joué
leur rôle et d'ailleurs c'est inscrit
dans la loi dans la constitution comme
vous êtes visiblement très inspiré je
vous invite à aller à retourner la lire
et vous verrez que c'est un script en
tant que citoyenne nous avons tous un
rôle à jouer
la spoliation de délation quand on
essaie justement de mettre par terre un
trafic de drogue
je pense que justement si on arrive à
voir ce lien de confiance entre la
police et les citoyens c'est plutôt
quelque chose de constructif par
ailleurs la justice a fait son travail
et les trafiquants ont été mis en prison
et vous voyez depuis quinze jours
et bien alors qu'ils ont connu un an
dans ce faire et bien les habitants
depuis quinze jours peut vivre de
nouveau en paix c'est simplement un
exemple pour montrer que quand on s'y
met tous quand on rame tous dans le même
sens
eh bien on doit y arriver et par
ailleurs je pense que dans cette société
il faut qu'on arrête d'être
consommateurs de tout on peut être que
quand ce matin de la sécurité ont d'être
acteurs de la cité
on doit être des citoyens responsables
éclairé et à partir de là et bien trente
secondes avec les caricatures de on
était dans la balance son port après
valence l'envers et maintenant
balancement voisins ça marche pas tout à
fait comme ça parce que désolé on va
arrêter dans ce pays
à chaque fois de tous car il
hier et d'un côté ceux comme vous qui
disent leur faut strictement rien dire
il faut se faire donc à ce constat
débrouillez-vous autres et de l'autre
côté excusez moi et de l'autre côté ceux
qui disent allez les gamins de 11 14 15
ans tous en tôle et on y brise non moi
je veux excuser moi je pense juste qu'au
mieux on peut parler de
responsabilisation de citoyenneté et
essayer aussi de sauver des gosses qui
aujourd'hui sont pris en main par des
caïds de quartier par des dealers qui
deale de la mort et qui utilisent ces
gamins comme de la chair à canon bah moi
je suis désolé je préfère en tant que
citoyen et en tant que père de famille
veut dire que ces enfants on peut
peut-être encore les sauver et pour les
sauver eh bien il faut casser
aujourd'hui cette spirale de la violence
chez moi ma crainte c'est qu'ici on ne
fait rien demain quelqu'un peut rester
sur le carreau
ça peut être un jeu ne sabotent un
policier mais je vous ça arrivera il
sera trop tard pour pleurer
françois 4 le mot de la fin rapidement
c'est vous le pouvez merci non je crois
que malheureusement beaucoup de jeunes
reste déjà aujourd'hui sur le carreau on
en a de trop triste exemple
et je crois que les informations ont les
arts si la police aujourd'hui n'a pas
les informations sur les endroits où se
déroulent les trafics de drogue c'est
que quelque chose ne fonctionne pas dans
la police ce n'est pas vrai qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui le citoyen pour aller
savoir que ces dons el hodoud dentelle
hall chacun le sait je vois dans les
quartiers qui sont autour de moi
la police sait très bien où agir temps
agir comment coco mots comment agir il
n'y a pas besoin de mêlée aujourd'hui
les citoyens sans les citoyens ont droit
aux droits imprescriptibles de l'homme
effectivement c'est la sécurité et pour
ça c'est à la police de faire son
travail mais qu'on lui en donne les
moyens
qu'on arrête de la démembrer d'un côté
et de dire aux gens finalement
débrouillez-vous il faut que vous
rentriez dans une guerre de tous contre
tous se débrouiller mais aucun moment
mes demandes et nous dans nos quartiers
la police fait son travail un des moyens
supplémentaires qui sont arrivés alors
arrêté 30 secondes caricaturer pas si on
pouvait jusqu'à l'arrivée des policiers
on s'est retrouvé avec 90 donc à moins
de moyens
excusez moi moi dans ma commune depuis
que je suis arrivé d'augmenter le nombre
de policiers qu'augmenter nombre de
caméras et jeu des policiers nationaux
supplémentaires parce que je me suis
battu donc les moyens quand on veut on
peut
et c'est aussi ça la force de
l'engagement politique merci en tout cas
à tous les deux on aura compris vos
opinions respectives
conciliables ce soir mais c'est la force
du face-à-face merci à vous deux
alexandre vincent d et françois cocq
sida et colère des policiers donc on en
parle est un gros également des
agriculteurs avec une manifestation
aujourd'hui à paris un rassemblement
pour protester contre les négociations
en cours à bruxelles sur la réforme de
la pac dont un accord est attendu pour
la fin de semaine la contestation a
dégénéré lorsque les forces de l'ordre
ont voulu déloger les exploitants venus
bloquer la direction générale de pôle
emploi illustrations sur ces images de
charles beaudry les exploitants ont
obtenu une rencontre la semaine
prochaine avec le conseiller agriculture
des manuels mais quand on écoute et le
porte parole de la confédération
paysanne au micro d'rtl france quand
nous revient rendez vous avec emmanuel
macron c'est à dire que on va aller à ce
rendez vous avec paul ii le duc
on va aller encore une fois discuté avec
lui lui porter tout ça mais on va
surtout elle et lui porte et que l'on
veut en rendez vous avec le président de
la république c'est à dire que l'on n'a
pas claqué la porte la semaine dernière
du cso avec le ministre de l'agriculture
pour discuter la semaine prochaine avec
le conseiller agricole de l'elysée il a
peut-être encore moins de prise que le
ministre de l'agriculture
nous ce qu'on veut ce qu'on revendique 7
voir le président parce que la politique
agricole commune
lc 1 l'agriculture d'accord mais elle
sert l'ensemble de la société c'est un
projet agricole alimentaires écologiques
sociétales territoriale environnementale
et donc ça ça doit concernés au premier
chef le président de la république nous
on en appelle à son écoute à ses
arbitrages et c'est ce qu'on veut aller
lui porter le plus rapidement possible à
la suite de ça en amont du rendez vous
avec emmanuel macron va continuer à
mettre la pression dans les dates dans
les territoires dans les régions pour
continuer à imposer ce rapport de force
parce que là aujourd'hui c'est un
premier pas un premier petit pas mais
c'est pas les petits pas qui vont faire
la politique agricole commune et c'est
pas les petits pots qui vont changer le
modèle rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de joe biden qui
souhaitent faire la lumière sur
l'origine
qu'ovide cause animale ou fuite d'un
laboratoire le président américain a
demandé aux services de renseignement un
rapport sous 90 jours
ce qui est loin de plaire à pékin et
puis nous reviendrons sur la décision
suisse de mettre fin aux négociations
avec l'europe après des années de
pourparlers
[Musique]
oui
ce sont les trafics de drogue d'une
certaine façon qui sont peut-être les
meilleurs adeptes de la mondialisation
c'est à dire que ils ont inventé les
routes de la drogue bien avant que les
entreprises ne découvrent les bienfaits
de la mondialisation on ne visualise pas
à quel point ça peut être compliqué de
se retrouver avec dans son garage une
montagne de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose de
l'argent sale devient très rapidement et
très facilement en gris et puis blanc il
suffit de passer par quelques sociétés
écrans mais à côté de ça vous avez tout
un réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup
plus ouverte au cash à l'époque de la
crise de 2008 vous dit même que les
banques qui ont été beaucoup moins
regardante sur la provenance de cet
argent qui arrivaient pour renflouer les
caisses ça a été même dire nations unies
on a constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser qu'il se déroulera dans
la mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux buts en 2019
la chine a construit en une année
tempère plus de bâtiments que les états
unis
en quatre ans de guerre de 1941 à 1945
en affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en
mer de chine du sud pékin fait prévaloir
des droits historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance hébergeant la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre société vit un moment très
important dans la lutte contre les
violences de l'intimé violence de la
maison il y à chaque année 300 mille
personnes victimes de violences
sexuelles
70% des plaintes classées sans suite et
un nombre de condamnations
d'ailleurs en baisse mais autour de 1000
condamnation par an nous devons
progresser de deux manières
la première c'est par la loi et ensuite
progresser parce que nous appelons des
pratiques professionnelles protectrice
la justice à sa part dans cette impunité
comment souhaitez vous la faire évoluer
nous devons être concret pour que la
protection ne soit pas un mot mais une
réalité
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous cet
écho politique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité
les ide et courageuse des mots qui
comptent
aulas en soi vient de l'union
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h38 les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france si vous nous rejoignez une
enquête qui je cite sape les efforts
mondiaux de lutte contre la pandémie
c'est la réponse aujourd'hui de pékin et
washington dans le viseur de la chine
investigations demandées par giove a et
donne aux renseignements américains sur
les origines du kobe de 19
le président américain reprend la thèse
de son prédécesseur donald trump selon
laquelle le coronavirus aurait été conçu
en laboratoire ce que démentent les
autorités chinoises mathilde romagnan
joe biden demande aux services de
renseignements américains d'enquêté en
chine sur l'origine du coc vite 19
le président américain attend des
résultats dans 90 jours et veut dresser
une liste de questions à poser
directement à la chine et j'ai demandé
aux services de renseignement de
redoubler d'efforts pour rassembler et
analyser les éléments qui pourrait nous
rapprocher d'une conclusion définitive
les états unis continueront à travailler
avec leurs partenaires à travers le
monde pour faire pression sur la chine
afin qu'elle participe à une enquête
internationale complète transparente et
basée sur des preuves
la responsabilité de la chine était
pourtant une thèse soutenue par son
prédécesseur et adversaire à la
présidence donald trump
ce dernier a souvent qualifié le
qu'ovide 19 de virus chinois et soutient
que l'épidémie est parti d'un accident
dans un laboratoire de hauranne à
présent tout le monde est d'accord avec
le fait que j'avais réseau quand j'ai
dit très tôt que orale était la source
du côté de 19
parfois qualifié de vie riche chinois
pour moi c'était une évidence depuis le
début mais j'ai été sévèrement critiquée
comme d'habitude
la chine elle a toujours farouchement
nié cette théorie en début de semaine
pékin a accusé washington de diffuser
des théories complotistes sur les
origines de la pandémie au lendemain de
l'annoncé de joe biden la chine rejette
la légitimité d'une nouvelle enquête
dans son pays
mallet 20 les états unis ne se soucie
pas des faits et de la vérité ou de la
recherche sérieuse de l'origine
scientifique
mais ils veulent utiliser la pandémie
pour susciter la stigmatisation et la
manipulation politique et pour se
soustraire à leurs responsabilités
ceci est irrespectueux de la science est
irresponsable envers la ligne et j'en ai
de plus cela sape les efforts mondiaux
de lutte contre l'épidémie
cette enquête a été menée pendant quatre
semaines en janvier dernier à roanne par
des experts de l'om s et chinois malgré
tout le patron de l' oms à réclamer une
nouvelle enquête sur l'hypothèse de la
fuite de laboratoire rappelons que vous
ramenez l'épicentre de l'épidémie de
covin 19 les premiers cas ont été
identifiés fin 2019 dans cette ville de
la province du he bei avant que le virus
ne se répande dans le monde entier pour
devenir une pandémie et tuent près de
trois millions et demi de personnes
et pour en parler mon sens en direct
depuis new york avec caleb mot pas un
correspondant d'arte et aux etats unis
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir khaled maupin merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france joe biden
qui veut donc enquêté d'ici à 90 jours
il appelle les renseignements américains
à redoubler leurs efforts pourquoi cette
détermination et pourquoi maintenant
il est important de savoir que l'origine
des pandémies les maladies souvent très
étrange très compliqué il y a beaucoup
de théories différentes sur l'origine
par exemple utilise du sida d'entrer le
temps on a cru que la syphilis
venez avait été que rapportés en europe
par christophe colomb mais on sait
maintenant que cette théorie était
erroné et que cela syphilis écourtée
avant le voyage de christophe colomb
jusqu'aux amériques donc l'origine des
maladies est souvent complexe
en l'occurrence il s'agit d'un effort
politique est flagrant afin de
fiabiliser la chine afin de nourrir une
un récit rendant responsable la chine
si tu n'as table peu avait ordonné cette
enquête boucourt dit que c'était
politique et redit à raison que c'était
la promotion d'une rhétorique anti
chinoises de la part du gouvernement
mais comme celle jouve hayden kg fait
pour faire plaisir surtout au lobby anti
chinois au louvre séparatistes tibétains
parce que jobs ait en sa défaveur au
lobby anti chinois alors ils s'en tirent
à bon compte c'est un acte politique et
c'est dangereux
la science doit être de la science et
non pas de la politique clairement pour
vous il s'agit d'un prétexte à cette
demande d' enquête présente un prétexte
pour nourrir la guerre commerciale même
avec
la chine fait il ya des motivations
politiques désire faire porter à la
chine
le chat potté retombées économiques des
erreurs de gestion du gouvernement
américain la chine a subi là le pot vide
avant tous les autres pays du monde
lorsque la chine a traité qu'on avait
tous nos médias les ont des pattes comme
un et attire et retient une dictature
aux etats-unis le président l'a même pas
pu vous obliger à porter des masques
chaque état a développé sa propre
stratégie et la gestion était
catastrophique pourquoi parce que dans
ce périple n'avions pas tous le même
programme le système du marché libéral a
des intérêts différents
et cela déchire la gouvernance du pays
secteur et axione chaotique a eu un
impact dévastateur sur l'économie du
pays
plutôt que de parler des problèmes de
gestion de l'incompétence des chefs et
steyn au mieux on préfère développer une
autre théorie du complot disant que tout
cela c'est la faute de la chine
donc c'est un scandale et on détourne
ici le processus politique
joe biden quand ils demandent cette
enquête est ce qu'il s'attend à voir de
vrais résultats parce qu'on a vu les
enquêteurs de l'om ait enquêté en chine
ce n'est pas forcément évident donc été
là bas
donc est ce qu'il y aura vraiment un
résultat tangible
le fait aucun doute
quels que soient les résultats certains
ne les accepterons pas en fonction de
leur programme politique
le fait que cette enquête est été
commandés nourrit d'un programme
politique
c'est la mauvaise approche le fait que
nous ayons cette conversation à propos
du laboratoire de buran cela montre qu
en dessous de la surface non pas
seulement aux états unis le camp nou le
monde entier les gens se rendent compte
de la dangerosité du concept de la
guerre bactériologique
plutôt que d'essayer de rejeter le blâme
sur les autres plutôt que de promouvoir
des thèses car l'autiste la communauté
internationale devrait se fédérer et
interdire la guerre bactériologique les
armes biochimiques
si quelqu'un si un pays a ses armes
alors l'autre pays va essayer de les
développer afin de mettre en place une
politique de dissuasion et cela met
toute l'espèce humaine en danger il est
peu probable d'après les données
existantes que ces expérimentations sur
des âmes était à l'origine de la copie
19 mai toutes ces théories montre que
nous comprend bien aujourd'hui ce que l
chinois sont même raconté un siècle
dernier et de plus en plus probable est
que plus en plus vrai les armes
biochimiques sont un danger les armes
bactériologiques sont dangereuses et
tous les plus grands pays du monde
devraient se rassembler et se mettre
d'accord et interdire la guerre
bactériologique
car c'est une épée de damoclès au-dessus
de l'espace moderne et il faut se rendre
compte aujourd'hui corset de lin tanger
potentiel et l'interdire à l'avenir
alors revenons à nos moutons
cette enquête si la thèse de la fuite de
laboratoire et était avérée par cette
enquête
c'est une supposition quelles
conséquences qu'il pourrait y avoir sur
pékin on s'est peut-être une deuxième
arrière pensée de john dryden de pouvoir
affaiblir la chine par d'éventuelles
sanctions je ne sais pas d'où cela
rendra service
c'est un programme politique il existe
aux états unis de fox qualifié de lobby
chinois
certaines personnes accusées par exemple
et démocrates être au service de la
chine on a critiqué trop mal d'abord
perdu la chine et il ya d'autres
exemples dans l'histoire de des états
unis ou la chine est un sujet majeur
la société d'un verre par exemple la
fausseté des affiches dans tous les
états lui disant que la chine est à
l'origine du trafic her2 d'héroïne
mondiale alors que la chine en fait agi
contre les opiacés et l'héroïne
donc il ya une faction au sein du
gouvernement américain qui est obnubilé
par la chine la considère comme le grand
et miou et alors que l'économie chinoise
prend de l'avancé par rapport à
l'économie américaine qui souffre encore
de l'épidémie pour eux c'est le moment
idéal pour faire avancer leur programme
peter navarro qui n'est prise au sérieux
par aucun économiste leckie siéger au
sein de la mort à sion 30 et été
conseillé alors qu'il a passé toute sa
carrière à blâmer la chine pour tous les
problèmes du monde
c'est un exemple des dangers actuels
nous avons besoin de coopération d'un
métier c'est sur des questions
de développement de changement
climatique et d'autres problèmes
auxquels nous faisons face ce n'est pas
la bonne approche
en tout cas la chine a répliqué en
rejetant l la légitimité de toutes
nouvelles investigations à se caler dans
son droit à la chine de dit de dire ce
n'est pas légitime de vouloir enquêter
sur un sur un tel virus qui a fait
autant de morts dans le monde entier
ce n'est pas légitime de vouloir savoir
d'où ça vient quels que soient les
résultats de cette enquête en cuir s'en
servir comme base électorale est
connecté à un organisme américain donc
des chinois et cela pourrait rejeter la
faute sur les états unis s'ils ont
prouvé que le virus était parti de
google et comme je l'aï dit auparavant
le régime idéal à dire l'origine du mot
souvent très étrange très complexe
les scientifiques passent des années à
étudier mais là les sages de jeu pid et
même peut-être que dans le noir lien
jamais de réponse peut-être qu'une
première réponse sera démonté plus tard
des boulonnais et il ya des indications
que le coronavirus était en europe est
déjà en outre tenir dix neuf doc et
peut-être que nous n'aurons jamais de
réponse peut-être que les réponses
seront révisées à l'avenir la science et
la politique ce n'est pas la même chose
et nourrir la politique de sciences
c'est mal merci à calais maupin pourrait
cependant d'alerté aux états unis
d'avoir été avec nous
quatre jours après le déroutage d'un vol
ryanair vers la biélorussie le bras de
fer se poursuit entre minsk et les
capitales occidentales notamment
bruxelles
selon le chef de la diplomatie
européenne le président loukachenko va
sentir je cite le poids des sanctions si
le g7 exige la libération immédiate du
journaliste d'opposition romane
protasiewicz à bord d'avions déroutés de
son côté moscou accuse l'occident de
jugements trop hâtifs la correspondance
en russie et d'antoine frérot sans
surprise la russie continue d'afficher
son soutien à son voisin sur ce dossier
le kremlin avait fait savoir hier qu'il
n'y avait pas de raison de ne pas croire
les explications des dirigeants
biélorusses
alors que le premier ministre grec a
déclaré cet après midi qui n'existait
aucune preuve de la présence d'agents du
kgb dans l'avion le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe a quant à lui
appelé à ce que l'on cesse de diaboliser
la biélorusse oui nous insistons sur la
nécessité de cesser de diaboliser ceux
qui ne plaisent pas à l'occident du niod
les premières minutes après cet incident
les autorités biélorusses se sont
clairement déclarés disposés à être
transparent a mené une enquête ouverte à
accueillir des experts en la matière et
fournir l'ensemble des renseignements et
des matériaux nécessaires elles ont déjà
diffusé une partie de ces renseignements
de manière unilatérale
mais le comportement de nos collègues
occidentaux surtout celui des pays
baltes est indécent du point de vue de
la diplomatie pour des pour moitié
jusqu'à mur comme du public
en effet le chef de la diplomatie
européenne compte faire payer le prix
fort alexandre loukachenko dans cette
affaire
josette borel a évoqué des pistes de
sanction des sanctions économiques en
particulier dans les domaines du gaz et
de la potasse afin de frapper la
biélorussie au portefeuille mais minsk
eux peut compter sur la solidarité de
moscou dernier exemple concret en date
la russie qui vient de faire savoir
qu'elle cesserait de délivrer des permis
d'arriver pour les vols en direction de
la russie qui contournerait le
territoire biélorusse
c'était le cas cet après midi encore
d'un vol qui devait assurer la liaison
entre vie
n et moscou c'est donc dans ce contexte
que vladimir poutine va recevoir demain
son homologue biélorusse à sotchi dans
le sud de la russie
cette année de négociations pour rien la
suisse a décidé de ne pas donner suite à
l'accord négocié en 2018 avec l'union
européenne pour stabiliser leurs
relations les explications en images
cela faisait plus de dix ans que l'union
européenne tentait de trouver un accord
avec la suisse un accord qui visait à
homogénéiser le cadre juridique
concernant la participation de la suisse
au marché unique et à instaurer un
mécanisme de règlement des différends
malgré un semblant d'accord en 2018
la suisse a temporisé estimant que
quelques points restés litigieux l'enjeu
de cet accord était de taille pour berne
puisque l'union européenne et son
principal partenaire économique en 2020
plus de la moitié des importations
provenaient de l'union européenne le 23
avril dernier un sommet entre le
président de la suisse guy parmelin et
la président de la commission européenne
ursula von der leyen s'est tenu à
bruxelles une rencontre au cours de
laquelle les points litigieux n'ont pu
être renégociés après des mois de
réflexion la suisse a finalement annoncé
ce mercredi vouloir mettre fin à ses
négociations
cette décision a été rendue publique par
guy parmelin dépendante de l'union
européenne au plan économique la suisse
réfléchit déjà à diverses mesures
d'atténuation afin de limiter les
conséquences négatives liées à la fin de
ces négociations et pour en parler nous
sommes avec à jean luc addor conseiller
national de l'union démocratique du
centre en suisse bonsoir jean luc addor
merci d'être avec son direct sur arte
france la suisse at-elle eu raison pour
vous de cas qu'elle apporte à l'union
européenne
claquer la porte sait on
on vit apparemment la fin de négociation
n'était pas vraiment parce que c'était
plutôt un diktat
on nous présentait depuis depuis un
moment
le résultat de ces pseudo négociation
comme quelque chose de non négociable et
puis nous on a regardé un petit peu
ce qui s'est passé avec la grande
bretagne
ça nous a encouragés à penser qu'on peut
survivre contrairement à ce qu'on essaie
de nous faire croire quand on quand on
essaye de négocier d'égal à égal avec
l'union européenne
c'est très exactement ce qui s'est passé
et puis je salue le courage du conte du
conseil fédéral qui a su défendre
l'indépendance de la suisse fasse
finalement la bureaucratie de bruxelles
et puis je pense que ça va donner lieu à
ça va donner un nouvel élan à de vraies
négociations entre partenaires
et puis pas entre le maître et son
vassal de vraies négociations enfin tout
de même ça fait quand même sept ans que
ça dure cette affaire de pourparlers on
les appelle comme on veut pourquoi aussi
longtemps pour finir par par capoter en
général on sait qu'on va pas faire
entendre un petit peu en amont quand
même non pour moi ce que je pense c'est
que depuis trop longtemps depuis pendant
toutes ces années on a négocié du côté
suisse avec une forme d'esprit de
soumission et puis ça s'est terminé
ça pour moi c'est la leçon à tirer
et puis maintenant ce qui semble
souffler du côté du conseil fédéral
c'est un esprit d'indépendance
et ça franchement je le salue parce que
encore une fois on a en a de l'espoir
qui est venu de grande-bretagne
et puis aussi pour les pour les peuples
européens pour les états européens qui
qui veulent conserver un semblant de
souveraineté
je pense que c'est un espoir mais c'est
un espoir d'abord pour nous au suisse
parce que nous tenons à conserver notre
démocratie directe à ce que nos citoyens
puissent continuer à donner leur avis
sur des questions importantes sans être
sans être soumis à des diktats européen
qui pourrait jamais remettre en cause
sans être soumis à des verdicts d'une
juridiction européenne à laquelle on
peut très très marginalement
participer et voilà donc c'est c'est un
signe fort d'indépendance et un
encouragement conseil fédéral a à
renégocier encore une fois dégâts il y
avait deux grandes craintes en lire les
analyses grande crainte des suisses
d'une part la protection des salaires
qu'il faut bien le dire sont plus élevés
que dans le reste de l'union européenne
la plupart du temps et la crise
migratoire également qui semble-t-il ont
échaudé les amis suisses on commence par
cette dernière
la suisse avait peur de quoi
concrètement de voir débouler sur son
sol les migrants oui bon c'est
exactement ça donc nous ne voulons pas
nous soumettre une une politique
migratoire à l'ipad vous l'immigration
le contrôle de l'immigration c'est c'est
un attribut très important de la
souveraineté la souveraineté c'est pas
juste se sont pas juste des questions
militaires
ce sont des questions économiques il ya
des enjeux économiques dans cet accord
ce sont des enjeux institutionnels il y
en a aussi
et puis ce sont entre autres également
des enjeux en termes de d'immigration
nous tenons dans ce pays à conserver
notre liberté de manom notre
souveraineté en matière migratoire est
la question des salaires également que
je le disais sont plus élevés en suisse
que dans le reste de l'europe vous avez
peur que d'appartenir en tout cas
d'avoir un partenariat très privilégié à
l'europe vous fasse perdre 7 entre
guillemets avantage évident qu'un un des
facteurs qui a puissamment contribué
notamment dans les les partis politiques
de gauche dans les milieux syndicaux qui
a puissamment contribué à a coulé cet
accord c'est évidemment la crainte
légitime parce que ce sont des évidences
la crainte que cet accord soit un outil
formidable de dumping salarial dont
finalement tous les travail des
travailleurs china passionnant les
suisses de passeport mais toutes les
personnes qui travaillent en suisse qui
bénéficie de nos conditions
là rien de normandie sciences sociales
pas ce sont toutes ces personnes ça fait
beaucoup de monde qui ont vraiment du
souci à se faire
si si on signe un accord avant c'est
maintenant que se sera pas le cas si on
tient là un accord tel que celui que
l'union européenne cherche à nous
imposer en osant port et ce qui fait
plaisir c'est que finalement ces soi
disant vous savez quand on est avec des
partenaires on se prétend partenaires
puisque ton travail avec avec le
chantage avec l'apport avec la menace
bâtonnets ça suffit et j'ose dire que
cesse le message que le conseil fédéral
je m'en félicite a su faire passer à
union européenne qui a le plus à perdre
finalement dans cet échec selon vous à
vous entendre on dirait que vous en
sortez plutôt bien et que c'est à
l'europe de regretter seulement d'accord
aujourd'hui c'est compliqué les
relations elles vont dans tous les sens
quand on fait là
le bilan de la balance commerciale
finalement on a beaucoup de raisons de
penser que c'est plutôt l'union
européenne qui est bénéficiaire
l'union européenne on est un pays un
pays petit peut être mais au centre de
l'europe y compris du point de vue des
transports des voies de communication
moi je pense que on doit revenir à de
vraies négociations entre partenaires il
y en a qui est beaucoup plus gros bien
sûr puis un autre qui est petit mais
chacun a des atouts à jouer
alors maintenant je pense que le message
c'est l'union européenne arrête de
chercher tout le temps à nous faire peur
on arrête de nous faire croire qu'on va
mourir si on n'accepte pas ces distincts
ses dictats pardon et on se met à table
entre partenaires loyaux
on joue chacun ses atours et je pense
que comme ça on a de bonnes chances
d'arriver passer l'intérêt aussi bien de
l'union européenne que d'un suisse la
suisse bien sûr elle est au milieu de
l'europe donc au milieu d'eux
de l'union européenne même l inverse est
également vrai l'union européenne les
pays qui nous entourent la france dames
en italie l'autriche
c'est donc c'est aussi leur intérêt que
d'entretenir des relations correctes
avec la suisse puis voyez on a deux pays
fin peu plus ce qui qui cherchent des
pays européens qui cherche à nous vendre
un avion de combat
je ne sais pas s'ils ont envie de le
vendre mais s'ils ont envie je pense que
c'est une bonne idée de se mettre à
table avec la suisse merci jean luc
addor conseiller national udc suisse
merci à d'avoir été en reste avec nous
dans quelques instants nous reviendrons
sur le discours d' emmanuel macron
prononcé aujourd'hui à kigali il avait
plus de valeur que des excuses estime le
président du rwanda
le chef de l'état a reconnu que la
france avait endossé une responsabilité
accablante dans le génocide des tutsi et
puis nous parlerons de la vaccination en
france mais prise de rendez-vous est
désormais ouverte à toutes les personnes
majeures
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
louis saillant est un mec ce commando
marine
il nous emmène dans les coulisses de la
guerre contre le djihadisme à au sahel
l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser l'extension du
terrorisme ne faut pas imaginer qu'il
suffit simplement d'avoir un pays pauvre
pour que l'islam c'est un guillaume a
qui sont embrigadés ils ont été séduits
ils ont été manipulés et d'autres qui
agissent de manière parfaitement
consciente et lucide je respecterai
toujours l'adversaire même si je méprise
totalement son idéologie comme c'est le
cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
mais en fait mine ici des commis tous
les deux à trois jours en france
actuellement pourquoi et shoots ont
encore à protéger totalement les femmes
on dit souvent femme posée en parler
briser le silence
nous savons que seulement 18 19 % des
femmes révèle les violences qu'elles
subissent donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80%
de femmes qui ne révèle pas les
violences qu'elles subissent aux forces
de sécurité dont celle qui rêvait il
faut vraiment les croix et les protéger
souvent on met toute la responsabilité
sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser qu'ils se déroulera dans
la mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux puissances
en 2019 la chine a construit en une
année tempête plus de bâtiments que les
états unis
en quatre ans de guerre de 1941 à 1945
affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en mer
de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits
historiques sur les règles
internationales
quand une puissance dominante constate
qu'elle est en train de se faire
dépasser par une puissance émergente la
tentation normale et de la détruire au
plan politique ou militaire avant
qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
21h soyez les bienvenus en direct pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi 27 mai discours aujourd'hui
d'emmanuel macro à kigali et l'avait
plus de valeur que des excuses et stream
le président rwandais
le chef d'état a reconnu que la france
avait endossé une responsabilité
accablante dans le génocide des tutsi
tout en précisant qu'elle n'a pas été
complices l'association de rescapés
ibuka regrette-elle cette absence
d'exclusion soir avec en invité le
parlement a définitivement adopté ce
soir le projet de loi de sortie de la
crise sanitaire ce texte donne le cas du
résidu déconfinement et institue le pass
sanitaires côté vaccination tous les
majeurs peuvent désormais prendre rendez
vous annonce le ministère de la santé
vaccinés le plus largement possible un
enjeu crucial pour l'exécutif afin
d'éviter de reprise de d'épidémie
ailleurs le coc vite toujours en espagne
fermé au public depuis mars 2020 le camp
nou reçoit des visiteurs depuis
aujourd'hui pour se faire vacciner les
installations du stade du fc barcelone
ont la capacité des demies seraient 500
doses par jour du côté de l'australie
c'est un autre scénario aurait confiné
pour 7 jours à partir de jeudi
melbourne et ses environs en réponse à
l'apparition d'un nouveau foyer de
contamination
en colombie plus d'un mois après le
début des contestations la tension ne
retombe pas la répression policière ne
fait qu'accentuer la colère des
manifestants
si cette réforme fiscale finalement
abrogée et qui est à l'origine de ces
mobilisations ces dernières se sont
transformées en une contestation de la
politique globale du président d'hockey
[Musique]
dix jours après la venue de paul kagame
à paris emmanuel macron a donc fait le
déplacement au rwanda cela faisait plus
de dix ans qu'un chef de l'état français
ne s'y était pas rendu le président a
reconnu le rôle de la france dans le
génocide de 1994 sans pour autant
présenter des excuses
une démarche qui est pourtant séduit le
président vendée et certains de ses
concitoyens
guyomard aussi responsable mais pas
coupable ce jeudi à kigali emmanuel
macron a entrepris de recoller les
morceaux d'une relation diplomatique
ébréché depuis plusieurs décennies entre
l'hexagone et le pays aux mille collines
étape incontournable de ce rapprochement
le président français s'est exprimé
devant le mémorial de kigali où sont
inhumés les restes de quelques 250 mille
victimes des massacres de 1994 un
discours au cours duquel le locataire de
l'elysée a reconnu le rôle de la france
dans le génocide
comme nicolas sarkozy il y a dix ans le
chef de l'état n'a en revanche pas
formulé des excuses
les tueurs qui ont hanté les marées les
collines les églises n'avait pas le
visage de la france elle n'a pas été
complice le sang qui a coulé n'a pas
déshonoré ces armes ni les mains de ces
soldats qui ont eux aussi vu de leurs
yeux l'innommable panser des blessures
et étouffer leurs larmes
la france pas complices certains
rescapés du génocide sont d'un tout
autre avis même si cet aveu de
responsabilité constitue pour certains
rwandais une étape importante ce qui est
bon c'est clair a reconnu la drogue
france
diplomatiquement mais lâché comme il l'a
fait c'est pas comme avant on se
souvient des français qui allaient sur
les barrières qui courait avec les ex
far qui les aider à distinguer les
métiers les motos quand même temps c'est
triste on peut pas oublier ça facilement
fait clair ils ont participé ils sont
aidés c'était le moment de dire pardon
clémencin placé à gauche at what
il n'y a pas eu le mans pardon mais
quand même il a fait un grand pas une
crainte les mode emmanuel macron semble
tout de même avoir fait mouche même en
l'absence d' excuses le président
rwandais paul kagame a salué le discours
de son homologue français c'était un
discours buisson avec une signification
particulière pour ce qui se passe
maintenant ce nom un de pointures will
et qui résonnera bien au delà du rwanda
ces paroles avaient plus de valeur que
des excuses
il faut dire que la visite du président
français revêt d'autres enjeux que le
devoir de mémoire la teneur du discours
d' emmanuel macron la nomination d'un
nouvel ambassadeur de france au rwanda
un poste vacant depuis 2015 et
l'annoncent de 500 millions d'euros
d'investissements dans le pays devrait
contribuer à une normalisation des
rapports bilatéraux entre paris et
kigali
les réactions sont partagées des
déclarations mélenchon mais décriée par
marine le pen
nous partageons la formulation du
président français emmanuel macron pour
les phrases suivantes
la france n'a pas compris qu'en voulant
faire obstacle un conflit régional où
une guerre civile
elle restait de fête aux côtés d'un
régime génocidaire en ignorant les
alertes des plus lucides observateurs la
france endossé alors une responsabilité
accablante dans un engrenage qui a
abouti au pire alors même qu'elle
cherchait précisément à l'éviter
aveuglement des autorités politiques de
l'époque certainement responsabilité
dans les massacres n'ont pensé le
contraire ou dire le contraire comme le
fait le président de la république c'est
faire injure à tous les français
militaires civils membres des ong qui
ont dès le début et durant le génocide
tout tenté pour sauver et protéger les
victimes demander pardon comme le
déclare emmanuel macron ce qui pourrait
le faire ne sont plus là où se taisent
mais ce n'est pas aux français de 2021
aux responsables politiques
d'aujourd'hui de le faire et pour en
parler nous sommes avec marcel kabanda
ancien président de l'association ibuka
bonsoir marcel kabanda merci d'être avec
nous le président macron qui a donc
reconnu à qui élit aujourd'hui les
responsabilités de la france dans ce
génocide
une première réaction cette prise de
parole du président français bonsoir je
trouve que c'est très courageux de sa
part d'avoir dit d'avoir dix sept
paroles d'avoir accepté des
responsabilités à cap brun tu de la
france et de l'avoir dit au rwanda à
kigali et au mémorial même du génocide
des tutsi là au repos de 50 mille corps
donc je tricote de sa part 7 c'est très
courageux
évidemment les rescapés beaucoup de
rescapés attendaient le mot excuse mais
je trouve qu'il est déguisé telle
manière parce que y'a pas excuses mais
la demande qu'ils demandent aux rescapés
de fernando de pardon
quand on demande pardon c'est qu'on
présente à la fois des excuses alors
justement le mot excuse effectivement
n'a pas été prononcé emmanuel macron qui
s'est justifié en estimant que
l'évocation des excuses n'étaient pas
appropriés qu'il préférait la
reconnaissance des faits ce que vous
partagez également cette analyse je
n'aurais pas je ne venais pas
indécent de sa part de prononcer le mot
excuse
maintenant il a choisi les mots qui sont
les siens ce sens et c'est sur ses
parents ben je les prends je les accepte
et je trouve qu'il s'est adressé au
coeur des ce cap est au coeur des
victimes
d'ailleurs je trouve que c'est très
particulier comme discours c'est un
exercice diplomatique d'état mais sans
difficulté qui centrait sur france 2
rescapés sur la mémoire et je trouve que
il a dit à sa façon ce que j'attendais
de lui
votre président rwandais paul kagamé lui
dit ces paroles avaient plus de valeur
que des excuses elle était la vérité en
éduquant comme vous le courage des
manuels mais kron vous êtes d'accord
c'était la vérité
skalli et le président français selon
vous aujourd'hui et il habille la
réalité un souci qu'il reconnaît que la
france parce que je vois léman j'entends
les mots leur hors de la france la
responsabilité politique je pense que là
il a dit la vérité
après on peut se demander si tous ces
hauts fonds il a repris le rapport du
clair dans ce qu'il a dit à kigali
mais la vérité c'est quand même la
reconnaissance de la souffrance des
victimes
et puis la vérité c'est ce que la france
le doigt
il apparaît de dette il a parlé de dette
donc tout ça c'est quand même la vérité
après dans les détails qu'est ce qui
s'est passé la marche
je ne sais pas si tout ça est vrai
mais le travail commence les archives ce
sens sont déclassifiés
je pense que les historiens vos avoirs
vont pouvoir commenter vont pouvoir
réfléchir sur ces deux énergies et nous
donner peut-être au fond il ya un
travail et un début qui est prometteur
pour un avenir réconcilier apaisé
injustement du coin qui est de nature à
apaiser les relations et marquer une
normalisation de ses relations
ça en prend le bon chemin selon vous oui
parce que vous savez c'est par
effectivement c'est pas la première fois
que le président sarkozy est allé au
rwanda mais il y avait dans cette danse
est dans la démarche de monsieur sarkozy
quelque chose dit passif et se tait il
passait sur l'avenir il voulait
construire un avenir mais ça sans avoir
500 a réellement éclairer le passé et je
pense que ce qui est avantageux dans la
démarche de monsieur du président
emmanuel macron c'est de ne pas c'est de
ne pas passer sous silence les faits
tous les historiens pour toujours les
éclairer mais quand même c'est mis sur
la place publique
donc je pense que là c'est une bonne
manière de passer à la page d'actualité
mais ça passait sans la lire celle du
passé je pense que c'est une bonne
manière clairement et c'est certainement
là le coeur du problème aujourd'hui de
quoi pour ceux qui n'auraient pas suivi
ce drame au rang d'art de quoi la france
est elle coupable selon ses détracteurs
bondé selon les détracteurs en deuil
avait dans votre sujet
quelqu'un qui disait que les france les
français vous savez de toute façon la
france est présente au rwanda
très fortement de façon très puissante
de 90 à 80 au moins à 20 93 et puis
revient au mois de juin 93 et la porte
au gouvernement du rwanda l'appui
politique militaire financier aux
budgétaire et pendant que la france
apporte à ce régime
autant d'appuis ce régime me prépare je
ne sais de ce régime commettent des
pogroms à plusieurs reprises les
massacres sont commis pendant que la
prendre le français les présentes au
rwanda et au côté de ce régime dit on a
entendu on a vu dans le rapport de la
commission qu'il y a eu des alertes qui
venait des rwandais qui venaient des
français des responsables militaires
français qui était au rwanda et qui
disait attention on est là entraide et d
un régime qui qui qui qui prépare un
génocide c'est dit c'est clairement
expliqué exprimés et et la france ne
peut pas ne pas aucune considération de
ses élèves donc à la fin c'est comment
nourrir monstres et après il dévore tous
ceux qui autour ça c'est une grande
responsabilité de donner les moyens de
donner la capacité d'agir à un régime
pendant que celui-ci prépare pas sur ma
la guerre contre la rébellion mais
prépare un massacre on à l'extermination
d'une partie de son peuple et c'est pas
acceptable après il y a 7
cette décision qui est prise par le
conseil de sécurité au moins d'avril 94
de réduire de manière drastique la la la
force des nations unies présentes au
juana la france membre du conseil de
sécurité
la pâte ne s'est pas opposé à cette
mesure par un amusant de son droit de
veto tout en connaissant bien les
pratiques la nature et de ce régime tout
en n'y a fait l'expérience de ses
capacités de ses ambitions et de celle
de sa probation a à connaître les clean
donc il y en a c'est ce que c'est un
aveuglement mais c'est un argument il
est volontaire c'est à dire une manière
de banaliser les crimes des massacres
voile juste un régime semble-t-il un pas
ça qu'on va l'aider mais il ne jamais se
rendre compte qu'au fond il ne fait pas
il ne va pas dans le sens souhaité merci
marcel kabanda d'avoir été avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes ancien président
de l'association ibuka merci à vous est
toujours en afrique la cedeao envisage à
la tenue d'un sommet consacré à la crise
au mali les militaires ont libéré le
président de la transition et son
premier ministre tous deux sous la
pression de la communauté internationale
grâce d'aia ils ont été libérés
le président de la transition banda au
et son premier ministre moctar ouane
emprisonné par la junte dans leur fief à
cathy depuis lundi il avait été poussé à
la démission
une décision justifiée tant bien que mal
cette démission font déjà suite or à une
série d'événements donc qui avait
empêché le fonctionnement normal de la
transition
donc il y avait des différends profond
dans sur la forme et sur le fond
ce qui concerne le fonctionnement de la
transition accusé de violation de la
charte de transition et de ne pas avoir
consulté le chef de la junte
assimi goïta pour la formation d'un
nouveau gouvernement
les deux hommes s'étaient vus contraints
de rendre le pouvoir si le conseiller
spécial s'était engagé à les libérer
progressivement pour la population
malienne et les militants qui oeuvrent à
une transition démocratique
ce fut la goutte d'eau l'action qu'ils
ont mineurs aujourd'hui certaines
actions kerma pour servir l'intérêt de
quelques groupuscules au sein de l'armée
ces gens cela au nom de quel droit
pendant lesquelles légitimité au nom
desquels légalité et aux noms les plus
nettes vague et s'empare du pouvoir
comme si c'était une question de un jeu
de cour de récréation entre des bébés
entre des enfants
le mali ne mérite pas ça je ne suis pas
de ceux qui sont dans le combat des
personnes habilitées le premier ministre
s'il est brûlant de la branchant à
francis est un programme entre la france
et le pro français est d'abord pour
malien nous sommes d'avoir dans un pays
démocratique et nous avons un principe
nous avons des valeurs du côté de la
communauté internationale les menaces de
sanctions s'était multiplié depuis lundi
l'union européenne avait notamment
menacé de prendre des mesures ciblées
dont un gel des avoirs et des
interdictions de voyager pour les
militaires et leurs collaborateurs
responsables du blocage démocratique la
diplomatie américaine
elle a directement annoncé la suspension
de son assistance aux forces de sécurité
et de défense du mahdi le porte parole
des nations unies s'était quant à lui
prononcé pour une reprise immédiate de
la transition dirigé par des civils et
le retour des militaires dans leurs
casernes
il est crucial que cette fille soit
résolue de manière urgente car le
constituant défi supplémentaire qui
affecterait négativement la mise en
oeuvre de l'accord de paix au lendemain
du coup d'état d'août dernier la cédéao
avait suspendu les échanges commerciaux
et financiers entre le mali et les
autres pays membres
une situation qui avaient fortement
pénalisé l'économie malienne
si des rumeurs
concernant la reprise du pouvoir par asi
meego ita le leader de la junte se font
entendre pour l'heure les responsables
de l'enlèvement semble avoir cédé aux
pressions multiples et affirme avoir
respecté leur parole en france sur le
front sanitaire le parlement a
définitivement adopté ce soir le projet
de loi de sortie de crise sanitaire
ce texte donne le cadre juridique du
déconfinement et institue le pass
sanitaires côté vaccination tous les
majeurs peuvent désormais prendre rendez
vous annonce année mi-journée du
ministre de la santé date effective de
la vaccination à tous sans restriction
le 31 mai soit lundi prochain à ce stade
24 millions de personnes ont reçu au
moins une injection et 10 millions ont
eu deux doses et dans l'hypothèse d'un
scénario favorable et français ils vont
donc très progressivement sortir de
cette crise sanitaire dans quelles
conditions exactement avec quelle
liberté et à quel prix pour en parler
nous sommes avec alexis poulain
éditorialistes et bonsoir alexis merci
d'être avec nous ce soir la version
finale du texte de sortir de la crise
sanitaire a donc été votée au parlement
quels en sont les grands axes
oui le sénat a voté avec le refus du
groupe partis socialistes et des
communistes et les écologistes sont
abstenus mais ça y est le plan de sortie
de crise sanitaire est approuvée par le
parlement avec le pass sanitaire
évidemment qui est dans le lot avec un
régime de transition avec les lois
d'exception jusqu en octobre 2021 et la
vaccination pour tous qui est va
s'ouvrir le plus rapidement possible
puisque les chiffres continuent
d'augmenter sur le nombre de français
qui choisissent la vaccination
on est entre a évidemment d'organiser
cette sortie de crise via l'application
tous sentis comme it vous aurez des qr
codes également à scanner devant les
établissements quelques les bars les
restaurants et autres et puis il faudra
montrer patte blanche en europe avec se
passe à lithaire européen qui va se
mettre en place un au delà du plat
sanitaire français pour pouvoir voyager
et montrer si vous êtes vacciné ou non
porter d'u coronavirus donc voilà c'est
voter sans vraiment de
grand débat sur l'aspect bioéthique du
fait de maintenant demander aux citoyens
français et d'autres pays européens
quel est leur statut par rapport à ce
virus c'est du jamais vu
et pourtant il n'ya pas eu de débat sur
la raison de cette mise en place
technologique de ce contrôle des
populations alors on comprend bien il ya
la pandémie certes mais est-ce que
c'était nécessaire
et pourquoi l'at on fait sans réel débat
alexis un autre sujet qu'on a abordé
cette semaine même
hier et avant-hier l'académie de
médecine qui a préconisé cette semaine
une vaccination obligatoire
un scénario possible selon vous en dépit
des bons chiffres de la vaccination
oui alors les chiffres de la vaccination
qui avaient été annoncés par l'exécutif
s'était 20 millions de vaccinés à la
mi-mai puis 30 millions à la mi juin on
est à 24 millions de primo vacciner donc
une seule injection donc l'exécutif va
sans doute tenir ces chiffres qui
avaient été annoncés le problème c'est
qu'on a maintenant l'autorité de santé
effectivement qui pousse gentiment tver
un vaccin obligatoire en disant
attention va d'abord le rendre
obligatoire à certaines professions des
professions de contacter les soignants
évidemment mais pourquoi pas les
chauffeurs de taxi les professeurs et
d'autres qui ont du mal effectivement à
se faire vacciner aujourd'hui on voit
bien que la prise de rendez vous pour
les français qui souhaitent se vacciner
beaucoup plus simple c'est beaucoup plus
simple d'avoir accès à la première dose
mais ça pose la question de cette
vaccination obligatoire et certains
d'ailleurs de ce groupe de travail sont
conscients que le rendre la vaccination
obligatoire pourrait provoquer un effet
inverse avec une levée de boucliers et
rendre plus compliquée la vaccination
donc on est petit à petit on continue en
fait cette stratégie du nuage
c'est-à-dire qu'on c'est à une stratégie
de deux comportementale qui pousse les
gens à adopter un comportement sans
avoir l'impression d'être contraints
c'est l'idée du passé ni terre
évidemment ses idées ses phrases qu'on a
entendu de dire si certains choisissent
de ne pas se faire vacciner ils auront
la vie beaucoup plus compliqué dans la
société qu'on leur propose donc
évidemment beaucoup de français vont se
dire moi j'ai pas envie d'être embêté
pour prendre l'avion pour aller au
restaurant pour faire ce que je veux
faire en fait donc je vais me faire
vacciner même si ce n'est pas
obligatoire le problème
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on entend des gens
comme alain fischer qui est le monsieur
minc sein du gouvernement
dire que pour atteindre l' immunité de
groupe c'est à dire le moment où on aura
suffisamment de gens qui ont des
anticorps face au virus
il faudrait peut-être vacciner les
enfants dès 12 ans et les autorités de
santé européennes est en train bien sûr
de regarder si ces vaccins fonctionne
c'est déjà le cas dans d'autres pays
et bien sûr la france suivrait en
faisant et pourquoi pas vacciner les
enfants le problème qui se pose c'est
pourquoi vacciner des enfants qui ne
risque pas grand chose du coronavirus si
ce n'est effectivement qu'ils sont
porteurs et qu'ils peuvent continuer la
propagation de la pandémie est là il ya
une vraie question à la fois sur le
consentement de mineur sur la place des
parents dans ce choix vaccinale et puis
sur le retour de ces technologies arn
qui sont en fait des technologies de
nouvelles et dont on ne sait pas ce
qu'elles peuvent faire dans les années
qui viennent même si les laboratoires
aujourd'hui nous disent qu'elles sont
absolument sûrs et qu'elles sont
efficaces
donc on est en train de créer en fait de
nouveaux problèmes sur cette vaccination
alors même qu'on arrive à vacciner
suffisamment d'adultes pour atteindre
potentiellement limitée troupes
dernière question quand on commente
l'actualité politique emmanuel macron
préparé un tour de france à quoi cela
va-t-il ressembler et pourquoi ce timing
alors emmanuel macron nous parle encore
une fois d'une grande concertation d'un
tour de france où il va prendre son
bâton de pèlerin aller voir des
entreprises faire des visites surprises
un peu dans les différentes régions
françaises
appelons un chat un chat emmanuel macron
entre en campagne il est en train de
faire une campagne électorale il va
aller au contact des populations des
différents territoires sans doute avec
des maires qui sont amies des régions
qui sont à plus tôt république en marche
il est en train de faire campagne avec
cette stature qui est celle du président
de la république mais ils maquillent ça
comme d'habitude comme il a l'habitude
de le faire
sous des allures de grande concertation
on connaît les grandes concertations des
malades macron il y a eu le grand débat
alors des gilet jaune ça s'est soldé par
des monologues des malaises macron seul
au milieu de foule silencieuse où il
prenait la parole pour expliquer qu'il
était le meilleur et que sa politique
était formidable il est en train de
faire exactement la même chose je crois
que on en a suffisamment souper des
grandes concertations de la république
en marche d'ailleurs ce parti rappelez
vous à commencer par une grande
concertation ce qui s'appelle la grande
marche ou les référents république en
marche à frapper aux portes des français
pour demander ce qu'il souhaitait faire
ce qu'il souhaitait voir changer dans la
politique française est bien
cinq ans après on en est au même point
avec emmanuel macron il est toujours à
nous vendre la même recette marketing de
la grande concertation alors qu'il est
en fait question d'une mise en scène de
sa personne et de défense de son bilan
simplement par sa parole qui va être
relayée évidemment parlent tous les
médias puisqu'il est président de la
république mais c'est une campagne
politique qui est en train de se jouer à
la fois avec les régionales mais surtout
avec 2022 en ligne de mire merci alexis
pour rester avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de l'espagne si
le camp nou est fermé depuis mars 2020
il a commencé à recevoir des visiteurs
aujourd'hui non pas des amateurs de foot
mais des personnes désireuses de se
faire vacciner
et puis nous irons en colombie plus d'un
mois après le début des contestations la
tension ne retombe pas et la répression
policière ne fait qu'accentuer la colère
des manifestants
[Musique]
le terme banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et on donne cette
impression de la banlieue ça se
résoudrait cas des jeunes violents
contre une police qui fait son travail
c'est plus compliqué que ça on est
français on est fiers de vivre dans ces
quartiers même s'il ya des difficultés
est la moindre des choses c'est
d'inscrire aussi notre empreinte canton
quand on participe à la vie de la
société et malheureusement il n'y a pas
cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers celle
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
se cache et politiques font pour les
gens mais sans les gens c'est à dire qui
donne cette impression de faire de
vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
[Musique]
après six mois de fermeture commerce non
essentiels terrasse ou encore cinéma ont
rouvert leurs portes le 19 mai lors
forcément le redémarrage peut parfois
être laborieux déjà on a beaucoup
d'angoissé beaucoup d'endroits de
retrouver les équipes de reprendre un
rythme avec en plus des restrictions qui
sont délicates pour travailler
correctement les projections de
croissance et que c'est exceptionnel
on a eu je doute qu'elles soient
réalisées aussi facilement que ça il va
falloir quand même avoir une vision de
relance il vient d'accompagner un peu
plus longue
on navigue presque un petit peu a vu
quand les aides vont s'arrêter
il est assez probable ça fasse beaucoup
de dégâts parce qu'on va voir est le
deuxième coup fatal de rien et un autre
film en septembre tordre serait
dramatique pour la profession et
moralement le terrible où on nous vend
du rêve et malheureusement ça se
transforme vite en cauchemar
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
en avril aura lieu le 60e anniversaire
du vol de youri gagarine en ayant eu la
chance de m'entraîner avec nos collègues
russes j'ai vraiment plongé dans une
atmosphère où j'ai vécu auprès de méroé
gagarine était présent à chaque point de
bâtiments de salles de sport de place de
la cité des étoiles moi je crois
beaucoup dans la diplomatie scientifique
et quand vous parlez de la coopération
scientifique sur la station bihan ou la
station spatiale internationale
c'est une forme de diplomatie on a très
peu d'objets aujourd'hui qui peuvent
être des outils diplomatiques aussi aux
six ans
[Musique]
la dignité pour tous ce que ça apporte
aux enfants
c'est une confiance confiance en soi ils
ont soif d'apprendre et izm la
connaissance mais quelque chose les
blocs aussi dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les enfants de l'ambition ils
veulent à accéder à des groupes veulent
s'évader du quartier qu'est ce qui ne
fonctionne pas dans l'apprentissage à
l'école les professeurs des écoles fonds
nécessaires mais je rencontre des
instituteurs des institutrices en ce1
ce2 il ya des enfants qui ont vraiment
encore du mal à lire et à écrire
et c'est pénalisant pour l'enfant pour
la famille on oublie les parents qui
sont responsables du foyer est temps que
les parents ne maîtrise et ne parlent
pas le français à la maison basse
avaient difficile
[Musique]
21h30 souhaité bienvenue en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez début
de la vaccination massive en espagne un
bec cynodrome s'est installé dans le
camp nou stade mythique du fc barcelone
reportage sur place de l'esc listings là
c'est un lieu très particulier pour les
catalans nous sommes ici au camp nou et
l'objectif est de vacciner 7500
personnes en trois semaines
donc le célèbre et mythique stade du fc
barcelone devient un vaccinodromes et
c'est surtout un grand coup de
communication
le gouvernement catalan ne s'est pas
cachée d'expliquer que l'objectif est de
sensibiliser et inciter les barcelonais
à venir se faire vacciner dans une ville
où l'esprit du barça est très présent
alors tout a été préparé en coordination
avec un hôpital l'objectif est
d'immuniser pas moins de 500 personnes
par jour alors tout est rigoureusement
organiser les personnes peuvent prendre
rendez vous sur internet quand elle
arrive une première files d'attentes se
situe à l'extérieur puis elle entre dans
une salle du stade où quatre boxes
accueille les personnes qui se font
vacciner
tour à tour et enfin une salle d'attenté
permet de patienter quinze minutes afin
de s'assurer qu'elles n'ont pas eu de
réactions allergiques tout le processus
est très rapide et les barcelonais que
nous avons rencontrés se disent très
enthousiaste et très heureux d'être
présent pour cette première journée
je vous propose de les écouter je suis
très contente oui je suis fan de
football donc quand on m'a dit de venir
ici
qui dit super dans ma famille nous ne
sommes pas des supporters du barça mais
c'est parfait de pouvoir utiliser un
stade de cette taille pour la
vaccination
vu que cette année on n'a pas utilisé
pour les matchs et en plus je vois que
c'est très bien organisé ici je me suis
inscrite dès aujourd'hui pour me faire
vacciner avant j'étais contre et puis
j'ai eu des proches qui ont eu le vide
et donc plus vite on se vaccine mieux
c'est nous sommes ici devant le
campement devant la salle qui a été
habilité pour la vaccination comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi alors les
soignants se disent très satisfaits de
cette première journée
il explique qu'il n'y a quasiment pas
de désistement les personnes se sont
présentées à l'heure il n'y a donc pas
eu de retard par rapport au plan initial
prévu c'est aussi car le processus est
très rapide une fois que les coordonnées
ont été indiquées à l'entrée les
personnes sont rapidement dirigés vers
leur box de vaccination
c'est une organisation qui est très bien
rodée je pense que c'est important tant
que message envers des citoyens de
proposer un lieu emblématique comme
celui ci pour vacciner 7500 personnes
c'est un message important pour montrer
l'union dans la lutte contre la pandémie
pour transmettre au public que la
vaccination est positive est nécessaire
cette première journée aux comptes nous
donnent le coup d'envoi de la
vaccination massive en espagne le
gouvernement espère atteindre 70% de la
population immunisés cet été elokobi de
19 et son variant indien circulent
toujours en australie conséquence l'état
de victoria se confine pour la quatrième
fois depuis le début de la pandémie
julien dur où on ne plaisante pas avec
le co vide 19 en australie après
l'apparition d'un cluster ce sont près
de 5 millions de personnes qui devront
rester chez elle durant une semaine à
melbourne et dans le reste de l'état de
victoria
alors que seulement 26 personnes
semblent avoir été contaminées la
politique sanitaire du pays reste
toujours très fermes notamment avec les
variants le variant indien fait que vous
êtes plus susceptibles de transmettre
l'infection si vous êtes vous-même
infectieux et cette sorte de hausse de
la transmission ainsi que la quantité de
virus que la personne de transmettre fou
que la prochaine personne sera prêt
susceptibles d'être infectés nous savons
donc ils raison de ce qui s'est passé à
l'étranger que ces variants rendent la
prise en charge bien plus difficiles
donc il est vraiment important que nous
ayons un confinement
comme cela a déjà été le cas les écoles
les bars et les restaurants vont fermer
tout rassemblement sera de nouveau
interdite et le port du masque sera une
nouvelle fois obligatoire dans les lieux
publics
logiquement ce quatrième confinement
provoque la colère des entrepreneurs
combien de fois le gouvernement de
l'état va-t-il attendre des petites
entreprises qu'elles paient pour tout
cela
d'où va venir l'argent je veux dire nous
avons eu des clients ce matin qui disait
vous savez le gouvernement doit faire ce
qui est juste
nous comprenons ça mais quelqu'un doit
payer et ce n'est pas moi qui vais me
plaindre
en attendant l'aumône du gouvernement
mais il doit y avoir une consultation
avec notre secteur et les grandes
centrales
les habitants ne seront autorisés à
quitter leur domicile que pour des
besoins impérieux notamment celui de se
faire vacciner
une campagne de vaccination défaillante
qui pose donc de nombreuses questions le
premier ministre par intérim de l'état
de victoria
james merlino a accusé le gouvernement
fédéral d'être en partie à l'origine de
ce confinement
il souligne notamment la lenteur de la
campagne de vaccination contre le commis
de 19 le déploiement des vaccins dans
notre pays a été plus lent que nous
l'espérions
c'est en fait il n'est pas à la hauteur
de nos attentes
si davantage de personnes étaient
vaccinées nous pourrions être dans une
situation bien différente qu'à l'heure
actuelle
malheureusement ce n'est pas le cas oui
un ange
alors que l'australie contre 25 millions
d'habitants seuls 3,7 millions de doses
ont été administrées
depuis le début de la pandémie trente
mille personnes ont été infectées dans
le pays pour moins de 1000 morts
les tensions s'intensifient entre
manifestants et forces de l'ordre en
colombie depuis début mai le payer de
tête de nouvelles manifestations
fortement réprimander par la police
colombienne
hélène masquelier
lance grenade canons à eau la foule est
la cible des forces de l'ordre qui
tirent à balles réelles depuis près d'un
mois les manifestations se succèdent en
colombie un mouvement de colère
alimenté par une violente répression du
gouvernement
plus de 40 personnes auraient été tuées
depuis début mai des slogans tels que
duke et d'émissions résonne dans les
rues de bogota
cali ou medellin à l'origine de cette
révolte une réforme fiscale très
impopulaire qui sera finalement retiré
mais le mouvement désormais transformée
en contestation politique globale vise
directement le président ivan bouquet et
son gouvernement de droite ceux qui sont
au pouvoir ne veulent certainement pas
écouté c'est pourquoi nous sommes
toujours là a résisté
nous sommes toujours là à nous battre
chaque jour jusqu'à ce que le peuple se
fasse vraiment entendre demandons un
meilleur pays
la fin de la corruption qu'il cesse de
voler de l'argent et que nous ayons tous
les mêmes possibilités de nous
développer sur le plan économique et de
l'éducation qui est la chose la plus
importante
le racisme les inégalités sociales le
chômage élevé le trafic de drogue et
l'omniprésence des milices et des gangs
alimentent aussi la colère des
colombiens ils réclament des réformes au
sein de la police de la santé ou de la
justice
en guise de symbole des protestataires
ont incendié ce mardi le palais de
justice de toulouse dans le sud-ouest du
pays
un acte qui a fait réagir le
gouvernement dit van dyck et je regrette
et condamne ces actes de terrorisme qui
cherchent à semer le chaos et la peur
des attaques comme celle de ce soir à
toulouse cesse d'être du vandalisme et
se transforment en actes terroristes une
manifestation pacifique et légitime la
violence est un crime
gouvernement a entamé des négociations
avec les protestataires
sans succès en attendant la répression
policière ne cesse de s'amplifier
à un an de l'élection présidentielle la
violence qui gangrène le pays ne semble
pas devoir s'apaiser de sitôt et pour en
parler nous sommes avec roux think
you're ego avocat constitutionnaliste
franco-colombienne bonsoir madame merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
vous êtes à bogota tout d'abord quelle
est l'atmosphère sur place les forces
anti émeutes sont toujours présentes
oui cela tous mexique l'invitation à la
mousse mais il ya toujours beaucoup de
tensions mais si demain on accomplit un
mois des manifestations et jusqu'à
présent il a pas eu de véritable
dialogue entre les gens qui se manifeste
et l'événement est un véritable aimant
volonté politique à court pour trouver
les sorties démocratique à cette crise
et jusqu'à hier soir là par exemple à
bogota et dans d'autres villes
on a assisté avec ces mots de trélat
avait violation de droits main avait
salué la police et qui ne se respectent
plus et les familles les enfants
il savait gens des quartiers populaires
ils s'envoient les gars est partout on
dégage péril et en douceur qui
conçoivent et des véritables affectation
à la santé des citoyens et aujourd'hui
et nous avons assisté à la une
proposition des motions de censure aux
milices pour la défense aux combles et
la république a été rejeté
puisque
majorité des parlementaires sont des
lapins l'événement et les si sa
responsabilité politique a été démontrée
et par les chiffres par des vidéos par
des et beaucoup de ces provinces à deux
policiers et lui à la tête de ministères
de la défense et devrait démissionner et
on soupçonne a fait part à la corruption
et par là pas de l'achat dé cette fois
les parent est monté bal à la finition
propositions des motions de censure a
été rejetée
donc ça va encore et ils sont alimentés
7 7 7 7 cette violence si vous voulez et
cette consultation et de la part de la
donnera de la jeunesse qui se manifeste
et qui va rester encore dans la rue pour
des mains accordé population soit en
sont ouvertes et on s'attend pas ils
démontrent les gestes des véritables
dialogues aux volontés les arrange les
choses avec les gens qui sont en
conformité
justement selon vous le mouvement de
contestation est en train de se durcir
alors qu'il dure déjà depuis plus d'un
mois il faut le rappeler mais les
problèmes chic et ça c'est maintien il
ya une volonté des gouvernements
d'écouter les gens et il n'y avait qu'un
comité de la démo mouvement social qui
aujourd'hui est dans la vue et là nous
coûter les sarries ils se montrent
aujourd'hui
son régime est forte avec plus de 350
des personnes à des gens qui sont
disparus on voit des signes et des gens
d'action trouver dans les rivières de la
colombie après avoir été tous tués et on
voit les chiffres et on n'arrive pas à
avoir des chiffres officiels qui
correspondent à au suivi des orangers
puisqu'il n'ya pas une volonté de la
part des gouvernements d'arrêter et on
peut déterminer les responsabilités de
tous aux paris qu'elles sont en train de
céder ses combines soir contre la
jeunesse qui s'est manifesté
pacifiquement et elle est notre côté il
n'a pas la volonté d attendre
il répondra assez c'est assez
proclamation comme le besoin des airs
formés et dit marisol touraine les
forces armées et pour qu'ils respectent
et les besoins humains et des droits
fondamentaux comme la manifestation les
oies protester et ça a du sens à mon
paquet c'est manque de volonté politique
malgré à moi des protestations des
manifestations et très nombreux dans les
différents points du pays et ce ne sera
pas s'arrêter si on n'arrive pas à
trouver et des tissus de dialogue et
avec keaven bouquet le président a un
dialogue doit absolument s'engager
par où commencer la prévention c'est le
pilier gier il juge des mandats c'est
l'arrêté
la collection s'appelle melon et de la
police dans des manifestations
pacifiques et d'arrêter les violences
policières et des manifestations contre
les commenter et à ces moments-là il rit
tous les plans cela qu'on supprime de la
justice que le donnait à ce moment là au
gouvernement et celle d'une structure de
restauration des forces de l'ordre pour
respecter les droits de l'homme et à
aujourd'hui et on n'accomplit pas c'est
ce qui a été demandé c'est une première
chose qu'on demande la démission de
l'actuel ministre de la défense une
forme et structurelle des forces de la
police et il série d'éléments dax perd
si longtemps et que les gens nous
attendent une réponse favorable de la
part des gouvernements et non pas relié
qui m'a fortement et l'ont pas répondre
avec un stigmatisation et la persécution
et ces gens qui sont très bons avec la
ville ces trois utilise bien aujourd'hui
que les gens qui sont inclus par des
chômeurs qui n'ont pas accès à
l'éducation vise à mettre sans aucune
garantie et la sologne consultés qu'ils
sont face à l'euro et alors oui et c'est
les manifester des solutions souvent
dans ce genre de situation quand il ya
des manifestations violentes
certains pays étrangers prennent parti
mettre la pression sur les dirigeants
jusqu'à parfois elle est à coups de
sanctions est ce qu'il ya des pressions
sur le président d'hockey par la
communauté internationale magie thierry
mal kické il ya deux jours on a des
côtés du mali violente a dit si
l'international
c'étaient des choses il faut aussi
remarquer et la condition
hélas la commission internationale
système américain de justice essaye de
venir en colombie et les gouvernements à
dénier la possibilité et
jusqu'aujourd'hui lachance signé lui
avaient dit qu'ils voulaient dire les
quatre et on n'était pas prêt pour
recevoir ce n'était pas un aujourd'hui
et 10 ans on n'était pas prêt c'est moi
cette condition et ils sont et tout ça
ça démontre et on vous cacher il sa vie
la communauté internationale daria les
dessins lui la réalité de l'article 6
passes en colombie et c'est comment tu
égard on attend qu'il a eu des poumons
ce moment de la partie
[Musique]
ils sont aidés léger ça vient après
après la transformation qui levait soir
et par les médias internationaux et de
la gravité de ce qui se passe en
colombie mais après il va falloir
évidemment quelle était la communauté
internationale et s'accroche au lobby
est par exemple ces moments là pour
vérifier la situation des droits de
l'homme d'état et sasuke sont commises
mais aussi pour le prochain sélection
qui vont se dérouler l'année prochaine
en installant et il va falloir avoir des
vérifications étaient leurs sherpas
scène internationale parce qu'elle n'a
pas confiance à ces scrutins
on n'a pas les garanties et on n'a pas
des instruments qui garantissent
élections transparentes
merci beaucoup c'est l'origine guégot
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france
dans le reste de l'actualité convocation
ce matin avant bassa de l'ambassadeur
français à tel aviv après les propos du
chef de la diplomatie jean yves le drian
qui craint un risque d'apartheid en
israël alors que l'onu lance une enquête
sur les atteintes aux droits humains
sept jours après le cessez le feu conclu
entre l'état hébreu et le hamas le haut
commissaire aux droits de l'homme des
nations unies considèrent que les
frappes israéliennes sur la bande de
gaza 1 pourraient constituer des crimes
de guerre michel baylet qui n'épargne
pas le mouvement islamiste dont les tirs
constituent je cite une violation
manifeste du droit humanitaire
international
les attaques israéliennes ont fait de
nombreux morts et blessés parmi les
civils ainsi que des destructions et des
dommages à grande échelle sur des biens
civils notamment des bâtiments
gouvernementaux des maisons et des
immeubles d'habitation des organisations
humanitaires internationales des
installations médicales des bureaux de
médias et des routes reliant des
services essentiels tels que les
hôpitaux
le résultat a été une destruction
partielle ou totale malgré les
affirmations d'israël selon lesquels
nombre de ses bâtiments accueillir des
groupes armés ou été utilisés à des fins
militaires
nous n'avons pas vu de preuve à cet
égard le proche orient où les rencontres
entre diplomates se poursuivent pour
maintenir le cessez le feu
walid bennani et des cris qui
retentissent au coeur des décombres mais
des cris de joie des enfants
palestiniens partagent un moment de
gaieté en compagnie de clowns et deux
doigts levés pour un appel à l'aide et à
la paix appel entendu du côté de doha le
qatar a annoncé mercredi une aide de 500
millions de dollars pour la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza une
journée marquée d'ailleurs par les
promesses du chef du bureau politique du
hamas
après onze jours de conflit en coûté la
vie à plus de 250 personnes
le mouvement islamiste a assuré qu'aucun
centime de l'aide internationale à la
reconstruction de la bande de gaza ne
seraient détournés promettant un
processus transparent et impartial à
yacine noir constructif mais aussi
vindicatif se mue en plus que jamais en
chef de la résistance palestinienne
vous savez et le monde entier sait
quelles sont les véritables raisons qui
ont conduit à la récente escalade des
violences liées aux pratiques de
l'occupation à jérusalem à la mosquée al
aqsa à cheikh jarrah et en général il
était impératif que notre peuple et
notre résistance et leur mot à dire et
met en oeuvre les avertissements des
dirigeants de notre peuple contre cette
occupation des promesses scrutées alors
que l'occident se tourner vers le proche
orient
ces dernières heures les rencontres
diplomatiques se multiplient
le ministre britannique des affaires
étrangères dominique rabe est parti à
leur rencontre des deux camps
objectif consolider le cessez le feu
entré en vigueur le 21 mai bien sûr nous
voulons que le cessez-le-feu soit
respectée nous voulons soutenir israël
mais nous voulons aussi que les
palestiniens trouvent une voie vers une
paix durable
c'est peut-être difficile pour l'instant
mais nous devons continuer à essayer
nous fournissons une aide humanitaire et
de secours en cisjordanie à gaza
nous apportons notre soutien merci et
merci à vous et au premier ministre
boris johnson pour le soutien ferme et
inébranlable de notre droit à
l'autodéfense lors de la récente
opération ce fut très appréciée la
grande-bretagne pays alliés mais aussi
favorable à une solution à deux états
qui passe par une stabilité au sein de
la région tout comme les états unis
anthony blinken bras droit du président
américain n'a d'ailleurs pas manqué de
se rendre en egypte puis en jordanie
deux nations et ont signé un traité de
paix avec israël
la france s'est par ailleurs inquiétée
par la voix de son chef de la diplomatie
jean yves le drian d'un risque
d'apartheid
après les violences observées entre
communautés juifs et arabes
il analyse qualifié de leçon de morale
hypocrite et mensongères par benyamin
nétanyahou en iran la campagne pour la
présidentielle commence ce vendredi une
période qui s'annonce mouvementée au
cours de laquelle les candidats vont
devoir se montrer convaincant pour
éviter un boycott du scrutin
écoutez les précisions de julien duroux
à la proche de la présidentielle
le climat dans l'ancienne perse semble
plus axé sur la défiance que sur la
confiance et les appels au boycott se
multiplient en cause l'invalidation de
plusieurs centaines de candidatures
ce qui laisse le champ quasi libre aux
ultra-conservateurs qui sont au nombre
de 5 sur les sept n'ont qu'a retenue le
conseil des gardiens de la constitution
parmi les premiers à approuver cette
disqualification
l'ayatollah ali khamenei appelle le
peuple iranien de se rendre aux urnes
deux à trois semaines du scrutin
j'espère vivement qu'avec les efforts du
peuple iranien cette élection qui va à
l'encontre de la volonté
l'ennemi préservera la réputation de
l'iran nos ennemis ainsi que les gens à
l'intérieur du pays qui sciemment non
relais leurs paroles utilisent tous les
moyens pour que cette élection mène à la
défaite de la nation iranienne
[Musique]
j'espère que le peuple fera un effort et
que dieu tout puissant le bénir à pour
que cette élection soit une source de
fierté et d'honneur pour le pays
l'autre les rejets des candidatures du
conservateur ali larijani du populiste
mahmoud ahmadinejad et du réformateur et
chaque jean gaury ont le plus fait
réagir au lendemain de cette décision le
président roannais a annoncé avoir écrit
au guide suprême mercredi
lundi matin nous avons été informés de
la décision du respectable conseil des
gardiens est dans la soirée son choix
est devenu clair s'agissant des
candidats que ses membres retenus
en fait de nombreux hommes politiques
dont nous-mêmes souhaité un cas de
figure où le conseil des gardiens
accorderait plus de candidatures mais le
conseil voulait une configuration qui
représentent le fondement électorale de
l'iran
la variété d'une élection réside dans la
compétition que les candidats se livrent
si vous enlevez l'âme d'une élection
elle devient un corps sans vie
c'est donc sa vraie nature désormais
souhaitons une compétition acharnée pour
aboutir à une véritable les brochets en
iran la crise économique et sociale
suscite une grande colère parmi la
population
pour hassan droy nier son gouvernement
la solution à ses problèmes réside dans
les négociations de l'accord de vienne
sur le nucléaire et un retour des états
unis à la table des négociations
les conservateurs quant à eux
accuse le président de la république
islamique d'imputer ces difficultés à
l'occident tout en ne permettant pas aux
pays de surpasser les sanctions de
washington dc au 18 juin la campagne
présidentielle pourrait bien réserver
des surprises de taille et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera dans quelques minutes à 22h avec
david khalifa
[Musique]
si demain un conflit ouvert ce produit
entre la chine et les usa
on peut penser et se déroulera dans la
mer de chine du sud
car cette zone est totalement
stratégique pour les deux buts en 2019
la chine a construit en une année on ne
paie plus de bâtiments que les états
unis
en quatre ans de guerre de 1941 à 1940
en affichant ainsi sa souveraineté en
mer de chine du sud
pékin fait prévaloir des droits dits
historiques sur les règles
internationales dont une puissance
dominante constate qu'elle est en train
de se faire dépasser par une puissance
émergente la tentation normale et de la
détruire au plan politique ou militaire
avant qu'elle n'arrive à ses fins
[Musique]
bienvenue à novossibirsk